there is new concern in the banking
sector this morning following the
failure of multiple Banks this month
First Republic until recently the 14th
largest bank saw its shares plunge
yesterday despite a 30 billion dollar
Lifeline from 11 other Banks the news
comes as the Federal Reserve is
considering another interest rate hike
Jill Schlesinger joins us now to talk
about it Jill good morning good morning
so front page of the Wall Street Journal
Journal Diamond as in Jamie pursues more
aid for First Republic it's on the brink
of collapse should people be worried
well I think we have to all be worried
about this this is not something we
encounter where medium-sized Banks of a
couple hundred billion dollars in assets
are having runs on their asset base but
here's what I think is important First
Republic like Silicon Valley Bank had
this large percentage of uninsured
deposits meaning a lot of people had
accounts with more than the 250 000 FDIC
Insurance limit now as other Banks were
failing remember that the FED came in
and the treasury Department said we're
going to insure everybody everyone more
than 250 but they haven't made that
similar announcement for other banks
that means that despite 11 Banks putting
30 billion dollars into First Republic
70 billion dollars has left that bank
this month and I think that that's
what's cause for concern the idea that
maybe these 11 Banks which put 30
billion dollars in may try to do
something to help the bank out that's
actually good and also we have comments
that were just least where Janet Yellen
is going to deliver a speech later today
and there is sort of an implicit comment
that she put out that said hey if other
banks that are systemically important
run into a problem we're probably going
to backstop those folks over 250. all
right let's talk about the FED which is
meeting today to decide whether or not
to raise interest rates again will they
what are you hearing well the the
we know that and the Federal Reserve is
very clear they need to fight inflation
the inflation rate six percent
year-over-year now the problem is with
the instability in the banking system a
lot of people are saying hey go on pause
just wait chill out for a meeting the
problem is I think that if the FED were
to do that it sends a signal that they
are spooked about what's going on and if
we are really believing that this is
mostly about confidence and we need to
shore confidence I hear that the most
likely path for this two-day meeting is
a quarter of a percentage Point increase
whether or not you think that's good or
bad I think that's what's most likely
that way the FED can sort of say hey
we're dealing with inflation but we're
not raising rates by so much that's
going to further crimp the banking
system Market seemed to agree with you
was up big yesterday Jill Schlesinger
thank you very much as always great to
have you